واحدة من أكثر الممرات المائية ازدحامًا في العالم ،
وهي قناة السويس في حالة توقف تام هذه
الساعة
لأن سفينة حاويات
كبيرة جدًا تحجب الآن
كل شيء تقريبًا في كلا الاتجاهين ،
هناك تطورات سي إن إن جون
التالية من أبو ظبي
الآن فقط لتسجيل ما يقرب من 19000
سافرت السفن عبر القناة في عام 2019 ،
لذلك هذا جزء مزدحم من العالم ، فهل
نعرف بالضبط ما حدث هنا
لأنه من الواضح أن هذا
جزء ضيق جدًا من القناة ، فكيف توقف هذا
التحول جيدًا في الواقع أنت تتحدث عن هذا
الحجم  التي تمر عبر قناة السويس
، لا تقل عن 50 يوميًا وفقًا
لحركة المرور في الوقت الحالي ، لقد
بدأنا في الحصول على بعض الوضوح بشأن ما
حدث هنا ،
وهي عبارة عن سفينة بحرية دائمة الخضرة تعمل خارج تايوان.
الرياح القوية تحولها
أفقياً هنا إلى
قناة السويس قادمة من الجنوب إلى الشمال مباشرة
فوق
ميناء سعيد ، يكمن التحدي
في الانتقال من الشتاء إلى الربيع.
الفصل كما تعلمون
يتحول جون بسرعة هذا الصيف ، تحصل على هذه
الرياح الصحراوية
القوية وهذا ما حدث على ما يبدو ،
فهذه سفينة ضخمة حيث كنت أشير
إلى أن طولها 400 متر وعرضها 59 مترًا ،
وهي واحدة من أكبر السفن في العالم
التي تبحر فيها منذ عام 2018.
القدرة أو القدرة على
حمل أكثر من
20000 حاوية ، لقد شاهدنا بعض مقاطع الفيديو على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ويبدو أنها محملة بالكامل ، لذلك
هناك بعض الخيارات هنا على ما يبدو
هناك بعض القاطرات إذا نظرت إلى
مستندات التعقب التي يتم
تداولها الآن من
أجل  آخر 12 ساعة
يحاولون فيها تحريك السفينة ولكن يبدو أنها
استقرت في مواجهة الغرب في قناة السويس ،
فإن الخيار الآخر هو محاولة
تجريفها وإذا شعرت باليأس عليك أن
تبدأ في تفريغها
لرفع القارب أو السفينة  حتى جون عندما
ننظر إلى الموقف حيث يمكن أن يكون
ما
قبل أيام من أن يكون الممر المائي واضحًا
وماذا يعني ذلك في الواقع أننا
رأينا بالفعل حركة في
أسواق النفط بسبب هذا
نعم  تعلمون أننا تعرضنا لانخفاض سبعة أو ثمانية
دولارات في الأيام الثلاثة أو الأربعة
الماضية بسبب الموجة الثالثة من
اللقاح
أه التحديات التي لدينا أه في
أوروبا الآن لذا انتقلنا من
70 برميلًا إلى 60 برميلًا تقريبًا. برزت هذه الحادثة
عودة السعر واستقر الآن
حول
61 برميلًا وفقًا لـ tankertruckers.com
أه هناك عدد من السفن التي
تحمل
الخام السعودي الأمريكي الروسي والعماني أه يسافر
شمالًا وجنوبيًا ويحتفظ الآن بحوالي 10 ملايين
برميل يوميًا أي حوالي 12 بالمائة من
الإمدادات
أه ، لذا فقد استقرت السوق
ولكن إلى وجهة نظرك جون إذا استمر هذا
لأكثر من ثلاثة أو أربعة أيام
فلن يكون فقط صدمة لسوق النفط
ولكن أيضًا
لحركة المرور التي تحاول التعافي مرة أخرى
ثم هذا الانتعاش من  الوباء
خاصة في آسيا ، كانت
هذه السفينة بالمناسبة تسافر
من الصين إلى روتردام
أه وهي سفينة تبدو
محملة بالكامل وهو أمر غير عادي
لرؤيتها عالقة في القرن الحادي والعشرين
في القناة.
غير عادي جدًا حقًا ، إنها سفينة كبيرة
جون شكرًا لك